we're getting ready to go and meet
Sasha's first ex-wife Masha but this is
really lousy timing because I am nine
months pregnant and the baby could
basically come at any minute I can't
believe I'm meeting her you think I'm
nervous more than you why because she
was a crazy but this was a long time ago
Sasha and I have been engaged while
waiting for the k1 visa but I am going
to be Sasha's third wife Sasha was
married for the first time when he was
22 - Masha and he had a child with her
named Daniel but it was just doomed to
fail
she's a song difficult person so they
divorced then a few years later Sasha
met his next wife and they had their son
in the beginning everything was okay but
then things changed I start another kind
of job in Fitness when I became more and
more muscular she said I don't like you
it's not what I wanted I said okay I'll
find someone who will like that
something was me actually I knew you
were before this time yeah this is when
we were talking as friends
[Music]